bonjour merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france alors vous les avez certainement
vu un ces images de paris hier dans les
parcs avec une forte fréquentation
qu'est ce que cela vous inspire je pense
que il faut pas retomber dans les
erreurs dont la facilité de nous avons
connu au juste avant l'été et on a parlé
de déconfinement et on fait on a baissé
la garde
nous devons rester extrêmement vigilant
actuellement nous avons un confinement
et il n'y aura pas un déconfinement il
aura un allègement des mesures into de
vente d'abord être extrêmement
respectueux des règles nous laver les
mains tout le temps porter le masque
éviter les contacts inutile éviter les
endroits fermés avec des personnes pour
voir effectivement rencontré nos proches
mais limiter le nombre de contacts je
parle pas aujourd'hui déjeuner reald à
me revoir des personnes n'a prédit et
demain matin recommencer si nous nous
respectons pas à ces règles de base
la situation va rester tendu les
hôpitaux nous sentons un peu petit
frémissement positif en région
parisienne on restait encore en
difficulté et nous aurons un noël
pendant lequel ça va être très difficile
de se mouvoir et de pouvoir rencontrer
ses proches
alors il ya une dizaine de jours vous
réagissiez avec nous sur notre antenne
sur l' annonce dur confinement vous avez
dit que ce re confinement a lésé et tu
es un pari sur l'avenir
un pari en passe d'être gagnée on passe
d'être perdue pour le moment le baril
reste haut risque et nous voyons que sur
paris après deux semaines de couvre-feu
est un peu plus d'une semaine de
confinement
la situation s'améliore un tout petit
peu comme dans d'autres grandes villes
par contre dans le reste du pays nos
vaillants problème que des régions
entières restent avec une situation très
tendue avec beaucoup de circulation
virale et que le confinement seul
pas réussi à contrôler les choses ça
montre bien qu'il faut mettront pas en
place beaucoup d'outils et que si nous
voulons dans les semaines qui viennent
dans les deux ou quatre ou six semaines
qui nous restent jusqu'à noël pour voir
blessé un tout petit peu le niveau de
tension et favoriser les rencontres avec
nos proches tout en respectant bien sûr
les mesures barrières le port du masque
la distanciation avec nos proches mais
au moins pouvoir les rencontrer de façon
plus aisée
nous devons rester très vigilants nous
devons impliquer et renforcer les
mesures de telle façon que nous soyons
vraiment aux mesures de passer un noël
avec mon proche dans des bonnes
conditions
alors vous êtes chef du service
d'urgence de l'hôpital avis ça commence
à s'organiser dans votre hôpital
la situation est moins tendue sur les
hôpitaux de paris en général de paris
intra muros
ça reste un peu plus tendue dans la
périphérie de paris
ou peut-être le respect des règles a été
moins bon et il y a aussi un élément
favorable c'est que beaucoup parisiens
ont quitté paris pour aller faire le
confinement à l'extérieur je compte
peut-être ça aussi ça réduit la pression
à l'intérieur de de paris dans nos
hôpitaux ça va un peu mieux nous sommes
quand même sont très fortes tensions nos
hôpitaux sont très plein nous avons dû
augmenter le nombre de lits dévié devant
des patients qu'aux vide et le nombre de
lits de réanimation détiennent pour des
patients en ville
nous sommes toujours sous tension et nos
équipes sont toujours sous très forte
attention je dois vraiment saluer
l'engagement et médecins des infirmières
des équipes de radio
toutes les équipes de logistique et
toutes les équipes opérationnelles des
hôpitaux qui permettent de garantir
aujourd'hui le bon fonctionnement de
l'hôpital
que ce soit par les passions qu vide ou
que ce soit pour les patients non
qu'ovide dont nous avons l'obligation de
continuer à nous en occuper et de
garantir leur sécurité et la qualité de
lensois alors on dit actuellement
on est dans la deuxième vague à ce qu'on
doit s'attendre à une troisième à une
4ème bug est ce que un jour la france le
monde entier va en finir avec le coréen
avait repoussé une maladie avec laquelle
on va devoir apprendre à vivre
si je fais une métaphore nous avons eu
une première vague entre février et mai
qui a été une grosse vague et qui après
elle a été s'étaler sur les rives du de
l'été de l'arrivée de l'été du printemps
et de l'été
aujourd'hui ne sont plus dans ce modèle
nous sommes dans le modèle nous allons
avoir une élévation du niveau des eaux
et l'idée est de garder plateau et c'est
ce qui avait été annoncé par notre
président emmanuel macron c'est que nous
aurions un un plateau en avaient contre
5000 et 10000 enfin un dîner l'infection
par jour c'est à dire nous ne sont plus
dans le modèle une bague qui va durer un
mois ou deux équipes à disparaître on
nous sommes dans le modèle taper taux
d'infection entre 5000 et 10000
infection qui va durer probablement tout
du long de l'hiver avec des petites
poussées et des petites descentes et
nous allons avoir pendant six mois tout
le temps et cas l'objectif n'est plus
l'éradication virale politiquement mais
de garder un haut niveau de circulation
virale qui ne nous met pas en danger la
la qualité d'accueil des hôpitaux pour
les passions coville et le conte
l'occupation kobe de négatif et casalino
merci d'avoir répondu à toutes nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes chef
du service d'urgence de l'hôpital bichat
paris merci